there were certain qualities that i had
in my 20s
that i've been trying to recover in the
last couple of years
will smith's quarantine pod is ready to
be whipped into shape
on monday the 52 year old actor shared
this photo on instagram he wrote in the
caption
i'm gonna be real with y'all i'm in the
worst shape of my life
and i was like wow and his celebrity
pals had some fun in the comments
quest love wrote this is the most
amazing post in the history of social
media
his bad boys director michael bay joked
bad boy's final chapter
you'll get in shape i guarantee you
meanwhile ava duvernay assured the
blockbuster star
i see no worst here but not to fear the
fresh prince is already in the process
of reclaiming his former physique
i came very much prepared i came you
know in great physical condition for the
film
on tuesday we'll share this shirtless
boomerang video to announce his upcoming
fitness journey
and that i'll be chronicled in a new
docu-series on youtube he wrote on
instagram
this is the body that carried me through
an entire pandemic and countless days of
grazing through the pantry
i love this body but i want to feel
better the project is described as will
getting back into the best shape of his
life
and the actor challenging himself to
improve every aspect of his fitness
this is of course the second venture
between will and the streaming platform
in 2018 to celebrate his 50th birthday
will famously bungee jumped from a
helicopter
into the grand canyon the event racked
up nearly 18 million views in the first
two days
it's a whole lot easier to play older
than it is to play
younger upon the release of gemini man
where will faced off against a younger
version of himself
he told dt how the movie and the massive
stunt made him reflect on getting older
what would you tell younger will that
will in his 20s right now to kind of
prepare
him for where you are today well first
of all will in his 20s
wasn't listening to nothing that nobody
had to say so that
that's first and more first and foremost
i wouldn't tell his dumb ass nothing
right you know
so you know my birthday last year i went
uh i did bungee jumping out of a
helicopter
over to grand canyon and even a part of
that
foolishness was trying to
get rid of the the fear
that i had taken on as i became more
successful
i didn't i didn't become more brave i
became more fearful
as i got older right so young will
was wildly courageous
like he would to decrease courageous to
the level of foolishness
but i would want to ask my younger self
about the source of that courage because
i've actually lost
touch with that with that source i have
to manipulate it a little more now than
i used to